in recent weeks as the virus has spread
and economic hardship has followed we
have seen Americans unite with
incredible selflessness and compassion I
want to remind everyone here in our
nation's capitol especially in Congress
that this is not the time for politics
endless partisan investigations here we
go again have already done an
extraordinary damage to our country in
recent years you see what happens it's
witch hunt after witch hunt after witch
hunt and in the end the people doing the
witch hunt have been losing and they've
been losing by a lot and it's not any
time for witch hunts it's time to get
this enemy defeated conducting these
partisan investigations in the middle of
a pandemic is a really big waste of
vital resources time attention and we
want to fight for American lives not
waste time and build up my poll numbers
because that's all they're doing because
everyone knows it's ridiculous